[تصفيق]
عامه بيحب يجرب
وسبيرمنت بتاعه
كلنا
طيب مين فكر قبل كده في تاثير الموضوع ده
على البيئه او اذا كان اصلا له تاثير
الايادي قلت في ناس اوكي
اجدادنا بالفطره عشان نفهم الجمله دي
خليني احكي لكم قصه ونرجع لورا شويه
زمان
كانوا كان في كل بيت مكنه خياطه ده كانت
طبيعي وكانت كل الناس اللبس اللي بيبوظ
عندها بتصلحه او بيعملوا لبسهم بنفسهم
يعني
وكانوا بيشتروا اللبس في سيزنز معينه بس
يعني مثلا مره في الشتاء مره في الصيف
وخلاص او لو احتاجوه يعني واللبس ده لو
ضايق عليهم يعني انا لو ضايق عليا اللبس
هديل اختي كان فكره الهانمي داونز كومن
قوي يعني ان اختي تاخذ اللبس ولما يضيق
عليها بنت خالتي وكده يعني
دلوقتي طبعا الموضوع اختلف تماما بقينا
نشتري لبس كتير جدا جدا وبنركنه في
الدولاب ومعظمه مش بنلبسه لو عملنا جوجل
سيرش على كلمه هيطلع لنا كلام غريب كبير
زي مثلا الاستخدام
المسؤول
للموارد البيئيه وحاجات كده اللي هو غريبه
طب يعني ايه الكلام ده يعني ان مثلا لو
انا كومباني وعندي عمال بشغلهم هشغلهم
وحديهم حقوقهم لو بستخدم موارد الموارد دي
هستخدمها بطريقه سليمه
طبعا
ماضل بقى هو السائد دلوقتي في كل البراندز
صناعه الازياء ثاني اكثر صناعه ملوثه
للبيئه بعد البترول اكثر من 80 بليون قطعه
ملابس بتتصنع في السنه ده اكثر من عدد
البشر على كوكب الارض في لبس كثير قوي قوي
بيتحرق وطبعا ده بيعمل تلوث وبيعمل اهدار
ريسورسيز هم استخدموها والموضه سريعه
بتتسبب في هدر 20% من الميه العالميه 20%
ف 100 بليون متر مكعب من الميه بيستهلكوه
في السنه والرقم ده مرعب ان هو ممكن يكفي
احتياج الميه خمسه بليون شخص
في العالم في السنه
طيب انا عرفت الكلام ده كله ازاي انا ما
كنتش عارفه اي حاجه خالص بس هحكي لكم
القصه من الاول
مش عارفه تعرفوا الوكاله ولا لا الوكاله
ده مكان في القاهره لبيع المستعمل في
واحده صاحبتي ايام الكليه عرفتنا على
المكان ده وانا اول ما اكتشفت المكان ده
يعني اول ما هي عرفتني عليه حسيت ان هو
كنز حسيت ان انا لاقيه نفسي فيه قوي عشان
من وانا صغيره بحب اقعد اجرب بقى في
الهدوم واقصقصيها وماما طبعا كانت بتصوت
يعني
حسيت ان هو يعني المكان ده بيكلمني ده ده
مكاني يعني بس ما كنتش اعرف اي حاجه عني
يعني ايه تاثير الهدوم والحاجات دي خالص
ما اعرفش اي حاجه وهي خرجت من فنون جميله
واشتغلت كذا شغلانه وبعد كده اشتغلت مع
مكان سبيشل قوي هي ماركه محليه بتشتغل مع
الستات في لسانك كاترين وسيوه والصعيد وكل
مكان في مصر
وبتدعمهم وبتلاقي لهم شغل ومن الحرفه
الحلوه اللي هم عندهم وحسيت قد ايه ان
جميل قوي ان احنا نلبس حاجه وراها قصه
وراها هدف
في نفس الوقت وقع في ايدي بالصدفه فيلم
وثائقي اسمه
هو بجد لازم تتفرجوا عليه هو كان بيركز
قوي على مشكله الموضه السريعه من ناحيه
العماله في الدول الفقيره يعني بيشغلوهم
بقى زي ما انا قلت لكم ساعات طويله في هدر
في الحقوق بيشغلوا اطفال مشاكل كبيره قوي
من ساعتها قررت انا هقاطع هقاطع المحلات
دي كلها وحشتري انا واولادي بشتري من
الوكاله حلو قوي هشتري من ماركات محليه او
من الوكاله
وبعدين مره قبل الشيفت بتاعي في الشغل كنت
قررت اروح الوكاله كانت اول مره تقريبا
اروح لوحدي فبتمشى كده لقيت ستاند عليه
حاجات ب 20 جنيه و20 جنيه ده رخيص فاللي
هو اكيد هيبقى حاجات ينبقعه يا مقطعه فببص
كده في الاستاند لقيت بنطلون اصفر
بس يعني كل حاجه فيه تحفه البراند حلوه
الكواليتي بتاعته
كل حاجه ولونه اصفر تحفه ومقاسي كمان
فاللي هو كل حاجه فيه حلوه بس كان كله بقع
ما فيش حته ما فيهاش بقع
يعني عجبني بس اللي هو هعمل ايه مبقع يعني
سبته ونسيت خطوتين وبعد كده رجعت كده قلت
ايه ده ثانيه واحده انا برسم انا برسم على
الماركه المحليه على الهدوم فانا برسم كده
كده طب ما اجيبه وارسم عليه واغطي البقعه
اللي هيحصل يعني فحسيت ان دي ايه ده دي
بتاعتي اللي هو ايه ده وجدتها دي فكره
جامده جدا
فجبته واتحمست قوي ورجعت البيت ورسمت عليه
اهو يعني حسيت ان الريز نس يعني اللي طلعت
تحفه ومختلفه وممكن اعمل بيها حاجه يعني
انا لقيت هدف للباشن بتاعي يعني
بعد فتره سبت الشغل معرفش يعني كنت ساعتها
الجراه دي بس سبته واجرت وقررت هو ده اللي
انا عايزه اعمله في حياتي انا هشتري هدوم
مبقعه ومقطعه وهصلحها وهصور كنت وانا بعمل
كده وهقنع الناس بالكلام ده يا يشتروه مني
بقى هم يعملوا بنفسهم يعني
طيب بعد كل الكلام ده تفتكروا يعني انتم
لازم ترسموا عشان تصلحوا يعني لازم تعملوا
زيي خالص مش لازم تعملوا كده
يعني حاجه شخصيه جدا اهم حاجه بس ان انتم
يعني تبقوا واعيين تقروا اكثر تشوفوا
ساعتها قلبكم هو اللي هيوديكم في الحته
اللي انتم ممكن تصلحوا فيها زي انا لما
قلبي وداني للارت وان انا اصلح في الهدوم
بس مش لازم انتم كده يعني بس هديكوا برضو
كذا فكره ان ممكن فعلا تفرق جدا في
الموضوع ده اول حاجه اشتري اقل دي اسهل
حاجه هشتري اقل حشوب من الدولاب بتاعي
يعني دولابنا كلنا مليان هدوم ومش بنلبسها
معظمها فانا ممكن اشتري من اشك من الدولاب
بتاعي اشتري منه يعني البس من الدولاب
بتاعي ثاني حاجه نحافظ على لبسنا اصلا
القريه دي موجود نشتري حاجات الجوده
بتاعتها كويسه عشان تعيش معانا ولو باظت
او لو حصل لها حاجه بسيطه ممكن اللي هو
نصلح ها نتعلم التكس دي يعني ممكن نشتري
مستعمل زي ما انا بعمل او ممكن نشتري من
ماركات المحليه وندعمها
وممكن نجدد في لبسنا القديم نرسم عليه
نعمل الكلام ده ونجات كريتف
وحتى لو اضطرينا نشتري من الماركات الموضه
السريعه لان في كتير قوي مننا متعود على
محلات معينه يعني فيها ستايل بتاعه وفيها
مقاساته وفيها كل حاجه فخلاص نشتري بس
نشتري بقعي نفكر قبل ما نشتري هل هي حاجه
احنا هنكمل معانا هنلبسها كثير فنشتري
بوعي
وبرضو عايزه اقول ان لو احنا حسينا ان ما
عندناش حاجه في ايدنا نعملها لا احنا
ويهاب يعني عندنا قوه شرائيه لو الماركات
دي مش عايزه تغير من نفسها خلاص مش مشكله
بس احنا بنبطل نشتري هم ساعتها هيغيروا
الاستدامه زمان كانت اوبشن بس دلوقتي
للاسف اون يوبشن هي الخيار الوحيد الف
واحد بيحاول احسن من 100 واحد مثالي شكرا
[تصفيق]